Una introduccion breve hermanos,
Primero la belleza de Hebreos es reconocida por los teologos de todas las edades,
Hebreos es visto como el libro mas elocuente del Nuevo Testamento sin duda,
El libro mas elocuente y doctrinalmente hablando es uno de los mas importantes.
4 Who is the Author
¿Quien es el autor del libro?
No lo sabemos, pero sabemos con toda seguridad varias cosas: primero que el libro ya estaba siendo citado como escritura en la iglesia primitiva.
Y en muchos sectores de la iglesia primitiva en el mundo entero, conocido en esa epoca,
Antes del año 95 D.C.
Quiere decir que uno de los padres de la iglesia escribio el libro, eso si, uno de los padres de la iglesia,
Ahora la iglesia primitiva misma no estaba de acuerdo en cuanto a quien escribio el libro
Diferentes sectores de la iglesia le atribuian el libro o les atribuian el libro a diferentes autores.
Un sector grande creia que Pablo lo escribio,
Otro sector creia que Bernabe lo escribio, otro sector creia que Apolos lo escribio,
Una cosa es cierta, si El Señor hubiera querido que supieramos, nos lo hubiera dicho,
Es el unico libro que ademas de 1a de Juan cuyo autor es desconocido en el Nuevo Testamento,
En el Nuevo Testamento el unico libro ademas de 1a de Juan cuyo autor no se conoce con toda seguridad,
Por supuesto sabemos quien es el autor de 1a de Juan pero de Hebreos no.
Porque debemos dedicar tiempo precioso a un discurso sobre la evidencia de que era Pablo, evidencia de que era Apolos, evidencia de que era Bernabe y al llegar a nada,
Podriamos pasar literalmente toda una mañana dando evidencias de quien podria ser el autor y ¿que?
Y perder las bellezas que hay en este libro, porque este libro merece semanas, la eternidad para entenderlo,
Pero definitivamente, no vamos a pasar mas tiempo hablando del autor.